alors patrick pelloux s'est un peu
george clooney pour le look laurent
qu'est ce qu'on pense c'est un peu ça et
kouchner pour l'action voilà c'est un
mélange assez heureux entre les deux
alors d'ailleurs c'est en voyant bernard
kouchner s'occuper des boat people que
vous avez décidé de devenir médecin non
oui oui oui
oui bah oui on me demande de faire des
réponses plus qu
il vous aime bien bernard kouchner il a
dit en parlant de vous une belle gueule
qui parlent bien
bon vous êtes content pas content je
sais pas c'est quoi ce sont finalement
oui il ya des jugements un peu pire
je serai ministre de la santé un jour
non
non je sais pas je crois pas non je
prends pas en avant pour moi pour
l'instant n'ont pour l'instant j'ai un
combat social et syndical ministre de la
santé cc et c'est autre chose pour
nécessaire ce faire récupérez l'aspect 5
au 10 ans bouger la chose après
alors patrick pelouse est praticien
hospitalier à l'hôpital saint-antoine
oui c'est vous qui avez tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé au monde de l'hécatombe de la
canicule l'été dernier
c'est vous qui avez gâché les vacances
de mattei d'une certaine façon non
je les fais parce que je pense que
c'était mon devoir mon devoir de citoyen
mon devoir de médecin et voilà on a
sauvé beaucoup de gens et ça a été ça
n'a pas été simple c'est pas encore tout
à fait simple à apporter alors mattei
n'est pas dans le gouvernement raffarin
iii il n'a pas survécu donc lui non plus
à la canicule le seul qui a survécu
finalement c'est maurice papon faisait
remarquer
alors vous publié chez fayard un livre
qui s'appelle urgentistes donc on vous
raconter comment quinze mille personnes
sont mortes l'été dernier dans
l'indifférence générale
vous décortiquez soigneusement les
mécanismes de cette catastrophe
humanitaire notamment la chronologie du
drame et j'ai appris en lisant votre
bouquin qu'il faudra 60 heures pour que
les autorités rédigé un communiqué d'
alerte sur les risques de chaleur assez
terriblement long surtout quand comme
réponse vous aviez
des sarcasmes des des ragots ça sentait
un peu les égouts des fois et c'était
absolument insupportable et c'est pour
ça que le moment où vos collègues
journalistes ont rapporté les propos en
disant ce qu'ils sont en train de mourir
c'est des morts naturelles bah là vous
dites bomba faux faux faux faire quelque
chose faut fout un peu gueulé parce que
sinon c'est pas possible
alors dans le clip on voit très bien la
france d'en haut en vacances toutes les
élites sont absentes à commencer par le
président de la république jacques
chirac qui lui est au canada et puis la
france d'en bas qui se met au boulot
vous raconter d exemple extraordinaire
des étudiants qui font la tournée des
bars et des brasseries pour quêter de la
glace pour l'amener à l'hôpital un
cafetier qui apporte sa réserve d'eau
minérale pour la mettre au service de la
de la communauté et puis vous dites
aussi la généreuse armée antillaise des
hôpitaux de france à tous et antilles et
dans les inconnus se sont se sont
largement moqué il était au rendez vous
ah oui mais je peux vous dire que il y a
ce très mauvais termes de la france d'en
bas elle a quand même largement des
leçons à donner à la france d'en haut
parce qu'elle était présente sur son
lieu de travail et ils ont été
extrêmement motivés pour exercer une
solidarité dont on avait bien besoin et
à l'heure actuelle il y en a encore
quelques-uns qui essayent de faire
croire que
on a sauvé personne je peux vous dire
que grâce à ces actions spontanées de
l'ensemble des catégories
socioprofessionnelles de l'hôpital parce
que mon site bien entendu les
infirmières les médecins mais il ya
aussi les ouvriers
les cadres des personnels administratifs
tout le monde sait vraiment
mobilisés et on a sauvé beaucoup de
personnes alors dans l'entourage du
ministre mattei on a commencé par dire
que c'était la faute aux 35 heures ah
c'était la faute à oui c'était fou 35
heures après c'était une grande
manipulation de la gaule reeves été
manipulés par la gauche et bien sûr mais
c'est vrai que la mort je sais pas si la
mort est de droite ou de gauche je ne
sais pas si la connerie et droite ou de
gauche mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que ça a été quand même une
certaine synthèse de tout ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire en terme de communication
ça a été fait l'été dernier c'est
évident alors en parlant de
communication il ya un moment où on
mattei finit par apparaître à la
télévision quand il reçoit l'équipe de
télévision il est en chemise et quand il
parle au 20 heures de tf1 il est en polo
et vous dites que sa conseillère en
communication qui était celle de michèle
barzach d'ailleurs à une époque lui a
demandé de remplacer la chemise par le
par le polo c'est assez pittoresque mais
oui cela avait été rapporté par vos
collègues journalistes etc c'était
vraiment ça montrait comment mais le
matin même j'avais senti arriver le le
le
l'élément de contre-information vote ça
parce que je m'étais fait alpaguer en
quelque sorte par un des responsables de
la préfecture qui m'avait dit mais il
faut pas affoler la france le gros
fallait surtout ne rien dire et
finalement là avec un peu de recul on y
réfléchissant si on n'avait rien dit si
on n'avait rien fait très probablement
que bon on aurait dit à ses hôpitaux sa
main de moins en moins ça leur aurait
donné des arguments supplémentaires pour
conduire la très mauvaise réforme
d'hôpital 2007 donc une sorte de
privatisation des services publics et
puis on aurait eu peut-être une brève
vers le mois de février quand l'inserm a
sorti ses chiffres en disant il ya biel
est bienvenue une surmortalité depuis
quand même personne dans ma fille lui il
apparaît donc en polo au journal de 20h
et et vous dites qu'il ya une espèce de
petite brise comme sa légère pendant
qu'il parle tout ça est assez idyllique
alors qu'il ya des gens qui sont en
train de crever lui n'y est pas
forcément pour grand chose il est
responsable il est ministre il est
responsable mais à partir du moment où
les informations ne remontait pas
n'était pas juste où finalement il y
avait une sorte de désinformation qui
lui arrivait lui on peut estimer c'est à
lui de le dire maintenant si a été
soigneusement informez vous l'avez
rencontré après je les rencontre et
après on a eu un entretien de deux
heures où
c'était c'était assez convivial
voilà ça a été tout quoi je vous la fais
au charme oui et vous avez craqué non
dans tous les cas il faudra attendre les
chiffres des entreprises de pompes
funèbres pour savoir le nombre de morts
exact parce que par le ministère et par
les autorités on n'a jamais su en fait
on n'a jamais su mais heureusement vous
savez heureusement qu'il ya eu des
témoignages comme le reportage qui était
passé sur france 2 sur justement le cc
cinéaste et ses journalistes qui ont
filmé tout ce qui s'était passé au
niveau des pompes funèbres ces images-là
parle d'elle-même il faut pas les
oublier vous voulez dire les cadavres
oui ils sont dans des camions réfrigérés
s'arranger et oui en un geste il faut
pas oublier il ne faut il faut surtout
pas qu'on enterre scène canicule comme
ça a été un peu tenté par ont énormément
de deux responsables avec tous les
inconnus et les indigents qu'on a mis au
cimetière de thiais il faut absolument
qu'on analyse mais tout le monde faut
vraiment qu'on ait cette manière de
penser que finalement nous avons une
civilisation qui n'a pas su évoluer et
on a eu une catastrophe humanitaire en
france en 2003 voilà alors une faille du
système qui a fait vaciller l'état et
qui pourraient faire vaciller la société
si on s'intéressé un petit peu au sujet
de ces quinze mille morts à la
conjonction chaleur aux zones parce que
sa personne n'ose en parler en fait elle
est pour l'instant personne ose en
parler
parce que chaleur plus aux zones ça
donne quoi personne ne sait à l'heure
actuelle accord on a entendu constat
c'est affolant mais on a des constats on
a des constats on constate que quand il
ya des pics de pollution on attend en
temps un peu plus de crises d'asthme que
d'habitude mais il ya d'autres fois
c'est pareil un truc qui me choque
beaucoup moins c'est qu'on a mis
l'accent beaucoup sur les accidents de
la route et c'est très très bien qu'ils
aient moins de morts sur les routes mais
c'était de l'ordre avant qu'ils aient
des radars tout ça c'était dix mille
morts par an hélas ces vingt ou trente
mille morts chaque années dues à la
pollution ou non mais et c'est énorme et
c'est complètement tabou et j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'en parle pas du
tout mais c'est parce que il alla il ya
toute une problématique de la recherche
là dessus qu'ils demanderaient des
moyens considérables vous savez
notamment c'est l'été dernier on s'est
aperçu que l'un des indices qui était de
dire ce qui tue c'est la chaleur plus
humidité de l'air étaient faux ce qui a
le plus tuer ça a été le faible écart de
température entre la nuit et le juin
c'est pour ça qu'il est impératif que ce
qui nous donne la météo nous donne
quelques pas la météo de la nuit c'est
vraiment fondamental n'est pas déjà
qu'ils ont du mal pour le jour alors est
ce que cette etei est ce que c'était et
iront encore 30% des lits fermés dans
les hôpitaux parce que l'année dernière
il disait qu'elle avait 11 % en fait il
des 30 est-ce que cet été y aura encore
30% des lits fermés
j'espère que non et on se bat et on se
mobilise pour que ça soit pas le cas
mais à l'heure actuelle c'est c'est très
difficile parce que nous sommes déjà mi
avril
que rien n'a été construit ou prévu d'en
pratiquer ou très très peu d'hôpitaux il
ya eu une campagne pour maintenir un
maximum de capacité de lits ouverts
c'est dramatique
les peuls ou si la canicule frappe à
nouveau la france cet été les hôpitaux
peuvent ils faire face
si c'était maintenant non je le dis avec
d'autant plus d'assurance que ça a été
même reconnu par le ministre de la santé
actuelle est ce qu on pourrait se
retrouver de nouveau avec 15000 morts
oui très probablement si on ne réagit
pas vite dans l'est dans les semaines
qui viennent pour justement créer un
véritable lien entre les systèmes
sanitaires et sociaux de la ville et
l'hôpital et en cas d'attentât chimique
est ce que les hôpitaux sont prêts
non
on va les mains
[Applaudissements]
donc on n'est pas à l'abri que ça
recommence la free cloud l'été prochain
alors l'an dernier vous deviez partir en
vacances avec vos deux enfants quand la
crise a commencé et puis au dernier
moment vous n'êtes pas parti est ce que
cette année vous allez partir
bas je crois que ça va c'est partie
remise je crois que je vais expérimenter
les quelques week-ends prolongés mais à
l'heure actuelle je partirai d'autant
plus
en vacances avec plaisir si l'été s'est
bien passé et quelque part après ce qui
s'est passé
mon devoir sera probablement de rester
en fonction
décidément chaque année maintenant vous
êtes obligé de prendre des vacances en
septembre
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux